Hello, everybody. Welcome to the Zoom call.
Let's have a few questions today.
So if you have some questions to ask,
now would be a good time to do so.
Okay, let's step on to the first question.
Is it okay for someone with a cancer,
the pesticides deliver,
to try the Budweigh protocol?
So it's typically okay for anybody to try the Budweigh protocol at any time.
Unless your driver is dairy, that could be an issue.
But if even if you've been,
even if your driver is dairy and you stayed off a dairy up to this point,
and now you're thinking about trying the Budweigh protocol,
because your cancer is growing,
there's nothing wrong with that.
If you feel like you want to give the Budweigh protocol a try,
now if you don't know what the Budweigh protocol is for other people that are listening,
it's a mixture of cottage cheese and flaxseed oil.
And you blend that up with an immersion blender.
And that's the Budweigh protocol.
Now there's a recipe for it.
We have that on our website,
on a blog post.
But yeah, it certainly has some challenges as far as taste to begin with.
But if you get by that,
we've seen some tremendous results with it.
So I'd say,
absolutely, you can give that a try.
Another question,
my husband is interested in the supplement stamina,
the shield,
shield you supplement.
Some research on it suggests to avoid dairy meat,
sour, tasty, and citrus.
Should you put these foods completely,
or only would take you the morning dose of stamina?
Also, is this a safe supplement for someone with a cancer diagnosis?
Let me look up everything that's in that again,
remember off the top of my head.
So yeah, that is a safe supplement for anybody with a cancer diagnosis.
The only thing that you would want to be careful of
is if you had a growing
prostate cancer.
So for a person who had a growing prostate cancer,
and they're on androgen deprivation therapy,
then they might want to reconsider that.
I would definitely want to test for that,
at least that.
That would be the only downside.
If any women can take it,
anybody else could take it.
It's only that somebody would set an active prostate cancer.
As far as studies at Shell research that you said
that you should avoid dairy meat, fish, and sour, tasty, and citrus.
At the time, you're taking that.
I would just say 30 minutes away from that,
if we would be fair.
Otherwise, you're fine.
Do you want to be careful of tinctures made of ethanol?
So that perhaps the ethanol comes from GMO cord sprayed with chemicals.
So there's a lot of tinctures on the market that are alcohol based tinctures.
Alcohol based tinctures are probably not going to be made with organic alcohol.
So then you do have the possibility of getting GMO ingredients in the alcohol.
We use organic vodka with all our tinctures.
So, but I, you know, unless the tincture you're buying a store bought tincture,
even the ones that we sell at our store from other companies,
I don't know that they're all listed as organic.
So, if it's not listed as organic, let me just look up one product.
And as I do so, here's the deadline route that we use a lot of from professional formulas.
And it's, we don't have a picture of the back of the bottle.
It don't know that it's listed as organic.
So there could possibly be the GMO ingredients in any of these alcohol based tinctures.
The thing is, you're not getting very much of it.
So it's not like you're drinking, you know, a glass of, you know, people drink a glass of wine or an adric.
You're exposed to more GMOs than when you get a teaspoon of alcohol.
So I don't know how much I haven't looked at any studies.
I don't, you know, we don't usually tell people not to be drinking.
And we, you know, I don't drink.
So I haven't really done much investigation of that.
I know what, and it actually with us, they did a full, and it actually program different types of wine.
And I, that's not my headache. I remember the type of wine that was highly recommended in the research that they did.
But it was, it was even better than just organic.
So do you have to worry about GMO ingredients in a tincture?
I would say no, because even in an organic product, you're probably getting a greater number of GMO products.
You know, in, in an even organic products.
So because of cross contamination.
So you're only doing two teaspoons of a tincture or something like that.
You are probably not exposed to any more GMO ingredients that you are eating.
A meal of organic food at different times that may have cross contaminated GMO things in it.
So it's, that's just the world we live in.
It's so cross contaminated even the best things you do.
So, again, I wouldn't, I wouldn't put a concert event.
I think we're exposed to more things than that.
What you can get into that GMO chemicals in that tincture.
Where do you find organic vodka?
We just get it at the local liquor store.
So,
and I think the bag of, didn't we get that?
Did we get some of the cost score or something, too?
I can't remember.
But yeah, it's just, I can't remember the brand name.
Any Megan's on the call, maybe she can message me the brand name of that.
So, yeah, it was just at a regular record.
I think my chief plot last week, you read in no dairy, but you didn't mention whether I could continue low history foods and intraments and fasting.
You remember any of those results continued to my diet suggestions left.
Cyrex array had basically showed that I was creating antibodies to basically everything that I was eating, even low history foods.
I wasn't sure how strict I should be since the elimination diet didn't work too well on my GI issues.
So, I would just say you're trying to,
you're creating a lot more inflammatory cytokines by eating foods that you have antibodies against.
And you are in eating histamine foods, so I would just try to stay towards that.
Cyrex 10 array as best you can and introducing new foods and making sure that your tummy can handle them and not be as concerned with the histamine issues.
As far as, as far as,
fasting and maybe fasting, maybe keep typed diets and,
and doing intermittent fasting.
I mean, that, I don't, I don't test for that or say, so there's been a way to physiological test for that.
Is that good for everybody to do that? Yes, it can be good for everybody to do that.
How to get her basic doesn't need again, like I said before, does it really have to do that on a daily weekly basis?
No, but to do that on a, you know, on a, a variable basis can be beneficial.
Maybe you do it once or twice a week, maybe you do it.
You know, once or twice a week and only every other week doing it that way.
So, that would, with intermittent fasting is the way to go.
Plus, again, you don't do intermittent fasting if you're in a weight loss perspective.
You're losing weight and trying to gain weight, you don't do that.
So the brand of the organic vodka was prairie farms and it was available across both.
I do think we saw that we did get that at a regular liquor store as well, but I know we got a bigger bottle and possible.
Oh, that's cutters. I'm just following up with my question about high blood pressure that you addressed for me last week.
I have a drinking pomegranate juice in an effort to bring my blood pressure down naturally.
I see that it's very high in sugar.
I know it's natural sugar, but I'm wondering if in view of my breast cancer diagnosis, is that risky for me or maybe it's the risk for taking.
Again, it's, yeah, it has, you know, you're drinking four ounces of pomegranate juice.
I don't know how many milligrams, maybe it's 50, 40 milligrams of sugar in that pomegranate juice, but you, we don't want to try to have a good diet to help with your cancer, and then you have a diet heart attack.
So it was just an alternative way to help bring down your blood pressure.
Now, if you're monitoring your blood pressure on a database and say you're trying to do it, you know, in similar situations, and you have the same table, say you have the same chair.
We did similar time of day, similar set of stress issues around at that time.
So you try to get as accurate as you possibly can remember I said the whole blood pressure cups are not statistically extremely accurate.
So you try to mitigate other variations as well as you possibly can to get some level of accuracy in the testing.
And if you can see your blood pressure dropping with what you're doing, and maintaining a lower level, that's what our goal is.
And then you can back off on the pomegranate juice doesn't mean you have to take it all the time, just need to call that dog.
You should be received by cheek swab any minute along with the list of supplements take it. I forgot to include your digest on the list.
They also forgot to mention that I'm doing MMS cancer protocols right now.
You don't have to remind me of a clear digest.
I did get your cheek swab and I started working on it already.
And I did at that, but I did not add the MMS for a call so I'll do that.
Okay.
Thank you for that.
So again, when you're dealing with, you know, two different additions that can be contradictory treatment protocols for those two different conditions.
You do have to kind of weigh out the consequences of each.
And depending on where you are.
Oh, if you had high blood pressure and your cancer was growing like crazy.
And then I would say, probably not the best thing to do is to do the cognitive attitudes, maybe do blood pressure medication instead.
If your cancer is in relative state of remission, which yours is, would it be okay to do public gratitude for a few months to try to get your blood pressure down.
I would say that's a reasonable answer to the question.
Again, you're just trying to, you know, we're not trying to follow rigorous tendencies.
In our diet or our protocol or our lifestyle, we're trying to be reasonable.
And, and way out the clothes and tons of each thing.
Sometimes you need to change things for a period of time because you have other.
That's what we're making is going on and you need to tweak things and change things for a shorter time and go back to something different.
Oh, so I've been doing intermittent fasting for years, so it's not a problem that sometimes I wonder if it's hard on my readers.
Sometimes I feel like headed, you know, if it causes fighting cortisol because blood sugars get too low.
Okay, so if you do intermittent fasting and your blood sugar levels drop, that can certainly cause likeheadedness.
Now, you can see that the lightheadedness is from blood sugar levels dropping.
Or if it's from something else by testing with the glucometers, if you had a whole glucometer and you feel like headed, good time to do a think of Rick.
And to see where your blood sugar levels are, if they're at like 60 or something like that, then your lightheadedness is most likely due to the intermittent fasting.
And then probably intermittent fasting is not good solution for you because you're, you're ending up with a reactive type of calcium.
So usually if you talk to people that are really in the fasting, people with diabetes and or people with hypoglycemia by doing fasting can help bring that into balance.
But the truth is is that, you know, if you have hypoglycemia and you have, you know, kind of a chronic condition of a doing intermittent fasting is probably not the thing to do because that is part of the problem with people with hypoglycemia, they tend to skip meals and they tend to not be able to keep their blood sugar balanced.
So, if you have a glucometer at home, that would be the thing to do to assess it.
If you are feeling like headed, do we did a bit fasting and you think you're pretty yourself and tested your blood with a glucometer and it was at ID4, then it's, that's your lightheadedness isn't because of drop in glucose.
But it could be something else. It could be a blood pressure issue. It could be an adrenal issue. It could be, you know, it could be a lot of other things.
You know, it could be an immediate issue.
And then intermittent fasting still might not be a solution but you want to dig into what is the cause of that.
So, if you're getting lightheaded, you'll let her what, if you're doing intermittent fasting or what, lightheadedness you want to try to get to the root, you want to try to get to the cause.
Again, one cause of that would be hypoglycemia. Another cause of lightheadedness could be anemia.
The other cause could be drop in your adrenals, especially if you say, like at lightheaded, when I stand up from a sitting position, and I have to kind of grab the table and it calms down when I'm able to walk across the floor, go where I was going.
It might go to adrenal insufficiency, especially if you did a figure print at the time, and your blood sugar was with the normal right. That's what you would think of. So you've got to get to the root of what it is.
So, your comment, if you're doing intermittent fasting for years, it's not a problem for you to do it, but you wonder if it can be cause of some other symptoms, certainly can be.
Don't do it, it's not something you need to do.
It's just another thing that intermittent fasting could be really good to do with eye blood sugar.
So, if they can't get their blood sugar below 110 or something like that, it would be fast either.
Longer fasting could be beneficial to help get that back of the balance.
I have a glucose monitor, it's not bad lightheaded, just more angry, I guess, anytime I get my fasting blood glucose check at a lab, it's rarely below 90.
So, if you do have a glucose monitor that I would check at at those times, if you so desire to continue to do intermittent fasting, if you're getting symptoms doing something like that, maybe it's not something you should continue to do.
It's not that you have to dig in to investigate that, maybe it's just something that that's not what your body needs right now.
So, we have a hook easy tonight.
All right, everybody, we will see you next week, get your questions in and I hope you guys have a blessed week.
Fall is flying by, Christmas is only about seven weeks away. All right, you guys have a blessed week.
Bye bye.